are we living in a digital dictatorship
sounds an awful lot like a dictatorship
to me
if you look back at the colonial times
the big empires of the past were
conquering people's land
resources and even taking humans as
slaves today's
dominant colonialists are tech
billionaires conquering our minds by
exploiting knowledge
of who you are based on what you share
and how you behave
on the internet we've spent a lot of the
last few years building
systems that are more sophisticated than
any other company has at this point and
frankly a lot of governments too
and they are also colonizing the very
fabric of life
well bill gates is actually continuing
the work of monsanto
but are we even aware that we're being
colonized
it's important to realize that
billionaire philanthropists whether
they're george soros or bill gates or
whoever
are not the solution to our global
problems
when bill gates pours money into africa
for feeding the poor in africa and
preventing famine
what's he doing he's pushing the failed
green revolution he's pushing chemicals
pushing gmos
pushing patterns and when renowned
indian scholar and activist vandana
shiva
talks about patents it's important to
say that one company
holds the exclusive rights to gene
editing technology
editus medicine backed by bill gates and
google ventures
and all he does is have to run through a
computer into a genomic reading and then
take practice
so he's taking patterns through gene
editing he's taking patterns through
digital genomic mapping and if you think
this is a
wild conspiracy theory you should know
that around 20
of the human genome more than 4 000
genes are already covered
by at least one u.s patent that's right
pharmaceutical companies scientists and
universities
hold patents on many of our genes this
means that you need a license from them
to do research on the genes they
essentially own and that corporations
decide on
who can do research on certain human
genes as well as how much
any resulting therapy or diagnostic
tests will cost
this is outrageous to us but it's
completely in line with the only things
that billionaires understand
power and profits and to make sure we
don't rebel they mine
our personal data one young man
owns the primary means of communication
on planet earth
unimpeded by law and therefore unimpeded
by democracy
harvard's scholar shashana zubov is of
course talking about harvard dropout
mark zuckerberg these billionaire
dictators have used their enormous
wealth to hijack our democracy
this is a real threat and you need to
wake up
the problem is their power it's the
gatekeeping power
that allows them to manipulate their
users profit off of data
and squash competition i would argue
it's time to break these guys up i think
that they have become
too powerful and that markets are
failing
break up big tech before it's too late